welcome back to our lives specially in
the wake of the 9/11 attacks all of us
vowed to get to the bottom of what
happened the authorities were gonna find
and punish the people responsible but
somewhere along the way we lost the
thread that goal was replaced by
cynicism and secrecy a lot of secrecy no
one's ever explained why but for years
the families of 9/11 victims have been
pursuing a lawsuit against the Saudi
government they believe it was complicit
in the attacks and for the whole span of
that period the United States government
again it's not clear why has prevented
the declassification of critical
documents including the identification
of a Saudi official believed to have
assisted two of the 9/11 hijackers last
week though finally the FBI revealed his
name and they did it accidentally
his name is Mossad Achmed al-jarrah he
worked at the Saudi embassy from 1999 to
2000 Brett eagleson is one of the 9/11
family members suing Saudi Arabia he
joins us tonight but thanks so much for
coming on the show tonight who is this
guy give us a super quick explanation
why we should care about his identity
sure and and Tucker thank you very much
before I go any further I just want to
say thank you again for covering this
story why are you the only primetime
host covering this I don't know some in
rain I'm in Raich that's why it's well
you have the Attorney General of the
United States weighing in on civil with
civil litigation invoking state secrets
like it's almost as if who are they and
and why are they weighing in on this
it's almost if it's like oh they have
information about something that they
can't trust us with or we're not you
know mature enough to know it so anyway
I digress the point is is that I'm sorry
I'm sorry but let me stop you there you
don't degress that's at the core of my
interest here what are they hiding
they're not protect I don't I don't but
I don't believe that for a second I
don't something is going on here they're
lying for a reason and what is that Reid
and I'm so I don't know the answer but
there is one what do you think it is
Tucker it's disgusting
I lost my dad on 9/11 there are
thousands of other people who have lost
loved ones and family members and to
find out you know we know the Saudis are
murderous thugs okay that's one thing
but to find out that our own government
is taking their side in court they are
submitting in private briefings the CIA
and the Department of Justice are
submitting in camera private briefings
to the judge behind our backs nobody can
see it then they have this blunder where
this guy's names come out what's so
secret about that his name came out and
the sky is not falling Pandora's box is
not open
who is this guy Jarrah he was living and
working in Washington DC he was
traveling all over the country
he was coordinating with the hijackers
there is a hierarchy of command Jarrah
right down to the the hijackers handlers
in LA right down to right down to the
hijackers so why is this a secret why is
this case shrouded in secrecy why are
you the only one talking about this this
should be dominating news this should be
headline news
it's 9/11 it's the largest attack on
America soil and our government is
siding with the Saudis it's unbelievable
and not just this government but the
government before this government and
the government before that so there has
been a great long chain so they're
protecting some secret and the
conspiracy that I'm just the opposite of
a conspiracy nut I'm an open-minded
person but there's something going on
here and I like the Attorney General but
I wish he would come on the show and
explain so we can understand what the
hell they're doing and why I wish the
Attorney General would take a meeting
with us and explain if you're gonna stab
us in the back at least look me in the
eye and tell me why that you're siding
with the Saudis in this case and Tucker
you make a great point
it started with Bush it was perpetuated
by Obama and and Trump the jury's still
out you know he hasn't helped us yet but
I'm appealing to the President of the
United States tonight he needs to know
what his Department of Justice is doing
he needs to know that Grinnell and
attorney general Barr are misleading him
why are we continually shouting with the
Saudis we have clear evidence al-jarrah
was living in Washington DC he was he
was facilitating he was communicating we
have phone records we have mountains of
evidence on the Saudi complicity in 9/11
and when we don't hold them account
well things like Pensacola happen and it
goes and the list goes on and on and on
and it's time for us to stand up we are
Americans we're all we could time to put
our big-boy pants on
Tucker our government shouldn't be
telling us what we're capable of
understanding they shouldn't be
protecting any types of Secrets yeah I
mean it and I again I I like Rick
Cornell lot I think he's done a lot of
good stuff and I and I like the Attorney
General the United States but I don't
like this and I don't know why they're
doing this and I think we have an
absolute right as American citizens to
demand an answer and God bless you Brett
for demanding it and we're rooting for
you thank you for coming on Thank You
Tucker thank you I really appreciate it